the most incredible thing about this
whole crackhead episode
is how desperately
all of the different facets of the
political establishment by which i'm i'm
including the media i'm including big
tech here obviously the government how
they're all working together to try to
tamp down this story because it's
generating tons of bad press tons of bad
press from us from the conservatives
over this tons of bad tons of jokes from
ordinary people about this my wife right
now my wife is is uh traveling and
seeing her family she's at a hotel right
now she said this morning she walks
outside and she hears one hotel worker
say to another hotel worker hey man you
hear we're all about to get some free
crack pipes in the mail and they're all
all laughing about this so biden and his
entire administration is a laughingstock
the
establishment is going into overdrive to
try to tamp this down
notably
the
checking website
snopes
fact checking is it's not actually fact
checking it's just a way that the left
rebranded leftist opinion columns maybe
10 or 11 years ago to try to make them
absolutely incontrovertible so it would
have just be regular left wing opinion
columns but they say this is a fact
check
fact check republicans are wrong about
everything ten pinocchios facts right so
snopes
adjudicates the claim the claim is in
early 2022 the biden administration
endeavored to advance racial equity by
distributing crack pipes to users
mostly false snopes says okay what's
true what's full snope says what's true
in 2022 a u.s department of health and
human services substance abuse harm
reduction grant did require participants
to provide safer smoking kits to
existing drug users
huh
okay so it sound
sounds like the crack pipe thing that's
true but okay it goes on and says in
distributing the grants priority would
be given to applicants serving
historically underserved communities
okay so however okay what's false what's
false is this was just one of around 20
components of the grant program and far
from its most prominent or important one
despite being the primary focus of
outraged news reports
hold on so you're telling me it's true
it's true that biden was sending crack
pipes to people
but but biden was also doing other
things
so therefore it's not
true that but you just said it's true
that he did that we're not saying he
didn't ever do any other things i'm sure
he had breakfast too we're not but he
did this
right what about the racial equity part
the pr well snope says what's false the
purpose of the program was to reduce
harm and the risk of infection among
drug users not to advance racial equity
although that was a secondary
consideration
so you're saying that was the purpose of
it
the two claims here where biden's
sending out crack pipes and
he's doing it to advance racial equity
and you're saying what's true all of
that what's false none of that it's all
just completely true therefore we
conclude mostly false 75 pinocchios
please republicans stop
making fun of us
it's unbelievable
to look at i hope people take a
screenshot of of this page on snopes
they'll need to because they've already
changed it it was
not only were we in a position where the
biden policy was the mockery of the
entire country but then the desperate
attempts by the establishment to
alternately deny and defend the policy
right on the one hand they say this
isn't happening it's not true but on the
other hand yes it's also it's great it's
good it's very important to to do that
uh
that that became the mockery too and so
snopes had to just completely
completely change course and they did
they now say it's outdated
this is the new snopes
conclusion here
outdated context after a wave of grossly
misleading news coverage in february
2022 the u.s health and uh department of
health and human services stipulated
that federal funding would not be used
to include pipes in safe smoking kits as
part of substance abuse harm reduction
program this newly stipulated detail was
not originally available
yeah because it wasn't true then they
changed their mind and backtracked
because it was a laughingstock meaning
the assertions made in a first wave of
coverage had become outdated they're not
outdated they're not
they're not the claim is in early 2022
the biden administration tried to
advance racial equity by sending out
crack pipes that remains true
even though biden ditched the ridiculous
laughing stock policy that still
happened you can't deny that that
happened snopes while they're trying to
deny that it happened but it did it's so
funny if you read the original snopes
report
after they say this wasn't really true
they then go to defend the policy they
say it's perfectly logical
as a matter of harm reduction to send
crack pipes to drug addicts
i don't know what definition of logical
there were it doesn't seem logical to me
to send crackheads crackpipes but they
say no it's great it's it's not it's
both not happening and it's awesome that
it's happening and now they say it never
happened at all forget about it why are
they doing this
a lot of people are scratching their
heads why why walk into this why is
snopes tying itself into these these
illogical pretzels to try to defend and
deny the spiden policy there's a real
purpose it's not just because they
really like joe biden it's not just
because there are leftists at snopes
the reason they're doing this is to
censor conservatives who are making fun
of the policy
because snopes and other leftist
fact-checking websites
are used by social media
directly through the algorithms of these
social media companies to suppress
what they call misinformation
which in this case is just called
information just
truthful information about the policy
so what happens is if you post on
instagram or facebook or twitter google
or whatever if you post about this
policy
and snopes has come in there and said
this is a false claim
yeah we acknowledge it's all true but we
rate it mostly false then social media
companies will suppress what you're
writing
if a website if a news website like the
daily wire
publishes articles
about
this policy this very real policy
and snopes comes in and says no even
though everything they say is true we
write it mostly false the website's
going to get dinged the website's going
to show up less on search engines the
website's going to get much less play on
social media the website's traffic is
going to collapse the website's money is
going to it's just a way
to censor and suppress conservatives and
so we can laugh at them
we'd say oh snopes you look like a bunch
of idiots just carrying water saying
things that are obviously untrue but
who's getting the last laugh on this
it's actually the left it's actually the
democrats are getting the last laugh
because they are pretty effectively
suppressing conservatives on the
internet glad you like that clip
ring the bell please
ring the bell
subscribe get notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe there to the michael knowles
show leave a five star review we
probably just put up ten uh you know
leave two five star reviews if you can i
don't know i don't really know how it
works subscribe we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]